Most people don't want something that's not perfect.
I, on the other hand,...
...look at the special needs cats as the most beautiful souls in this world.
My name is Michele Hoffman, and I rescue special needs cats.
I created Milo's Sanctuary 17 years ago.
We have anywhere from 85 to 100 cats at one given time:...
...cats that are blind, with deformities, abused, sick.
They are kind of the unwanted of society,...
...and so, our job is to take care of them, give them a safe place.
The cats have taught me so much about life...
...because they don't know that they're special needs cats.
They're just cats.
I love them for their goofiness, their gentleness.
Being with them all the time brings me the greatest joy.
I really want to take the fear out of owning a special needs cat.
Empathize with them.